we're going to talk about git and this
is to do with version control protecting
your code
working as a team but these are all
things that
involve using something called git which
is about storing your
your code safely somewhere so we should
start by thinking with what is git for
because there's a range of things that
could be used for uh companies use git
to manage code across loads of people
you can use git for as like a remote
storage to keep it safe so it's not on
your laptop which we'll talk about you
can use it for versions of your software
but really in all of those cases what i
see get as being for us for protection
it protects your code from yourself
from other versions messing up or from
other people messing up your good code
when they're collaborating with you so
really get is a way to protect code and
make it safe and you should be using it
for yourself you should be using it when
you work with others and you should be
using it on projects that matter or just
on anything when you might want to go
back to something i've heard of github
and obviously loads of people will be
shouting at the screen right now of
course github github but is there a
difference between git and github well
so github is a online server
like set of repositories where you can
store your git projects remotely so
that's a great github is a great example
a website where you can
basically choose to push your code
remotely so it's not on your computer so
it's safe but there's other ones as well
there's like git lab is another one
which you can use and companies can also
set up internal servers with instances
of git lab for example and that means
that you can have one just within your
company
where you push to a different computer
in your company
you could even if you wanted to have
your own git lab server somewhere else
on a different computer in your house so
github is just
one of the companies providing git as a
service yeah i feel like they're sort of
saying
we're a hub of git projects you know
we're like a place where you can store
it um
but you they also provide lots of other
features which could be handy so those
features typically the ones that help
teams to collaborate
so they've spent a long time adding
features around git as a storage
protocol
basically to encourage teams to use it
the other thing some people might have
heard of is something like svn which is
another type of system which is storing
versions of your code but we're going to
basically not talk about those
differences here they're basically doing
the same thing different ways slightly
but we're really talking about how do
you use git to protect yourself rather
than exactly how git works yeah we
should start by thinking about using git
for yourself when you want to use git to
look after your own code to make sure
you don't accidentally break your code
because i'm sure loads of you like me
have got to a point where you've been
working on a project for a while and
suddenly nothing works and you didn't
spot exactly when you broke everything
but you've made quite a few changes
since you last knew that it did work
um so anybody that is carefully looking
after that code is going to be thinking
okay every time i do something good make
something work i'm going to
store it as a
period of time in my git repository so i
can always roll back to it that's like
the main function where you can use git
for yourself you're like protecting
previous working stages of your code
that you can always go back to sort of
save as you go sort of thing yeah save
as you go virgin history is really
useful but to get there you have to do a
few things so for a start we're
presuming you're working in like a
folder on your computer and that folder
is like a just a normal file storage and
you've got some files in there and git
is doing nothing with that until you ask
it to start doing something
and then when you want it to do
something you say okay
git init
which basically and this initializes git
in that folder presume you've got git
installed on your computer already which
you know most linux based systems have
um and then what that does is it creates
a little hidden folder so you could do
this by showing the contents of your
folder including hidden files which is
ls minus a on a mac for example uh on a
linux machine and that will show you
there is a new folder now in your folder
which is called dot git and it's all
hidden there doing a series of jobs that
you don't know that's happening it's
kind of i see it's like a magic folder
that is looking after all your code for
you and you could go into a whole video
at some point where you look into how
that dot git folder works but it's
essentially storing histories of
everything you're doing in that folder
from now on
but it's not quite ready at that point
you then have to do something else where
you say okay um i've got some files here
i want to tell git to manage them
so what you do then is a git add and
then the name of the file that you want
to put in and then from that point gets
like okay
i know about that file now from now on i
will always look at it and i will track
its status i won't do anything unless
you tell me to but i know it's there so
you could mean what you can have is some
files that git never knows about never
looks at and some files that git is in
charge of and that's really handy for
example if you need to have like your
own personal access token to a server
you have that something that git doesn't
manage only stays on your computer and
then your other people working on that
same project have their own ones that
get never managed but then you ask it
only to manage the files that you think
are important
i always consider git being like the
sort of robot that is managing your
files on the side keeping records of
them updating them if you ask it to it's
basically your your little servant
robots keeping
version of your file safe when you ask
it to so then what you have is
this special area that git knows about
an area that doesn't know about and then
a stage in between which is the staged
area which we're going to also talk
about so maybe it's handy to look at the
uh the
example folder i've got here on the ipad
so this is if we expect that the white
area on the ipad is a folder and when
you do git init what happens is it
creates basically three sections of that
folder is the way i look at it a section
that it does not care about which will
be here on the left
so let's say um call this normal and
then a git area that gets in charge off
so i'll put this over here is the get
area
gets air is bigger is that just uh so
you can draw yeah more space me to store
stuff in this demo
and then there's a staged area
so we'll call this staged so what
happens is uh when you first create a
file i create a file in there and make
my files green just represent as a box
and i'll call that version one at this
point git doesn't know anything about
that because you haven't told it about
it so to get to know about it all you
have to do is type in git add
file one or the green file what that
does is it says okay from now on i'll
put this in an area that git knows about
at least it's begun to see about it's
not in git's history yet but get knows
about it there if i had another file git
wouldn't know anything about that and i
could play with get as much as i want
and get whatever touch it so you have to
do this git add and then file name
to make it start to play with it
so then when you've got maybe a couple
of files in there and you want uh get to
store that as a point in time
what you then say is git commit and if
you do that what i'll do is i'll take
all the files that are in the staged
area which is all of these now
and it will put that into its history or
start to put into its history what it
will first do is say please can you type
in a message to describe this point in
history so that will pop up an editor
which you can configure to whichever
editor you want um but it will pop up
that editor and it will you just type in
essentially a message that represents
the current state and there's all sorts
of advice on what that should be
companies have policies on what that
message should be for every state that
you decide to save
but for yourself it could be whatever
you find helpful but then when you save
that message it then moves everything
over into the history and then puts the
message as like a little label up here
and then gives it like a special idea
hash code reference essentially for that
point in time so the files you see
because that's the most recent one and
the files you see in your folder are
going to look at those files there but
you can start to make changes so then
what you can do is you can say i want to
add to the second file this is where it
starts to get complicated so i want to
make
an update to file two and you're working
on that on this area which has not not
been told to you by git yet get sort of
knows it's there
let's do point one there we go
okay so then to get get to store that
for you
you have to say okay i've made a change
to a file and these are files i want to
store in the next history point so you
then say git ads and it will take this
and put it back into the staging area
because you said i want to add this to
the next point in history that i'm going
to store and so now when you say git
commit it's going to commit again the
things that are in the staged area so
then you type in git commit says okay do
you want you need to add a message to
that again so it pops up the editor you
add a message uh and then once you've
added that and closed it uh it then
moves that into the next version of
history so how this looks is you'll have
this here
you'll have another
message you put in there like that and
you've now got two stages of history
inside kit so what this means is you can
actually access any of those stages in
history again if you want to so there's
a few interesting things you can do but
if you ever want to see what your
history is you can first type in git log
and that shows you and we've got a
separate view for this that shows you a
kind of
history of all the things that you've
done so you can go back to any of those
times in the past so what you need to do
is you need to take a list of those
messages is it yeah so these this is
like a list history of the stages that
you've saved messages so these are the
messages i put in like hello for the
very first one made a new change for the
second one and then new file so you're
basically asking for one of those stages
in history back
so what you can always do
and it will warn you if you do this but
you can do it if you need to you can say
git check out and then the code that you
got for this special item in history
that kind of hash reference and what
it'll do is it will take that point in
history and bring it back to being the
current
files that you see and then you could
read from there what did i do
um
where was i
you potentially take some copies of
files if you want to store them
somewhere else
and then you can go back to the current
point in history by checking out the
code of the most recent one instead
so what that's doing is it's changing
the files that are in your folder so
your folder no longer is like a view of
your current files your folder is now a
view of files in a state of history
which might be the most recent state but
it could be any states in this history
is it literally like get this kind of
pasting those into your normal view so
you can see them but it saves all the
rest of it yeah one really fun exercise
actually is to make a file save it to
the git history using git commit make a
file add it to the gesture make a file
add to the git history
and then just have a view of that folder
open on your screen and then in the
terminal check out each of the stages of
history and you'll see it just adding
the files and taking them away and
adding the files and taking them away
and that's a really kind of
clear way to see that you are
switching between stages of history and
your view of your folder is always a
view of a stage of history that git is
managing and you're just choosing which
state of history you want to view
one of the problems with
checking out previous
old versions of your history is that you
can't really work on those and switch
back very easily so one thing they
always recommend is you can create
something called a git branch
now to make this confusing you're
turning your history which was linear
until this point
into a history that has a branching
point that you can switch between
which maybe we don't need to worry too
much about but you can essentially say
um so the first thing you do is you type
in git branch
and that will list all the branches you
currently have
and that will probably just be until
you've done something complicated that
would probably just be the master branch
um which is the one that everyone works
on by default because they haven't made
a policy for anything else companies
don't let you tend to do that but most
people are just working their own
projects on the master but say you
wanted to get a copy from your history
um but not disrupt your master branch
what you can say is
um
get branch
give it a branch name
like
uh when it used to work it could be the
name you know whatever you want it to be
and then you can um and then give it the
code of that point in history the hash
code from that point of history
and then what it will do is it create a
branch from that point in history to the
side that's called when it used to work
and then you can get check out when it
used to work and that will switch you to
the point of when it used to work now
all your files will show what's on that
branch which is a point in time when it
used to work but you can just switch
branch back to your master so this is
kind of an easier safer way to go back
to a point in history and see where
things work just by putting that point
of history into a branch so that's all
well and good if i'm trying to manage
what i'm doing but i'm i'm guess this
gets used across organizations with
multiple people and things does it yeah
so that's kind of challenging and one of
the things git will do which we can talk
about in another video in the future is
uh it will
always tell you when you've edited code
that someone else has edited
and so this is a really handy feature
protects code from other people or
protects you know you from damaging
other people's code that works because
sometimes you're working something you
make some changes and then you think
that's going to be great and then you
would you know commit them to the
project
um
but really what you've done is broken
something else that someone else has
done or some someone else has edited the
same file on the same day and you both
commit at the end of the day and it's
going to start you know
conflicting so git will always say hold
on a second you know there are
multiple changes here and if it can do
it then it will just merge them you know
if you've changed one file sometimes
it's changed another file git will just
you know put them both in to say hey
everything everything was fine you know
no conflicts there
um
but if you both edit the same file it
will say
okay before i will let you put this in
you really need to
tell me
the correct way to merge this because
it's it needs human intelligence to
merge it safely so it will say here's
the bits you made here's the bit someone
else made
delete one or the other or merge them
whenever you do and it will only accept
it once you've kind of merged those bits
and removed any metadata ads to it so
it's really clever at protecting you and
saying you can't do that until
until you check out what happens
and one of my favorite exercises with
students is to make all five of them try
and edit the same file on the same day
during the lab and that's when they get
to learn this kind of a process of
of working together and understanding
other people's code changes and how
you're going to affect them how you can
use github is uh is to have like all you
know gitlab i shouldn't prioritize one
company but um you can basically use
those remote servers to protect your
codes in case someone steals your
computer or in case you
spill water on a computer or in case you
delete the entire folder which if you
did you would delete the folder and all
the contents and the git robot that was
managing that code you know it would
just all be gone
so
in case of loss what people do is they
like to get push that code to a remote
server so there's a few different ways
of setting up one thing you can do is
you can go to these websites you can
create a new project and give it a name
and that's all fine and then it will
give you an address
and so what you then type on your
computer is you um
if you're in your folder with all the
files on it you so you type in uh get
remote add
a name which most people just use origin
and then the address that you just got
from that website
and what you're saying to them is okay
hey git robot there is now some space
online that i want you to use and every
time i i type in git push i want you to
push all the changes to that remote
location and it will then store it
safely up there and that's great that
means you can
if you if you do lose your computer or
say you go to visit a friend or your
family and then someone message you
saying oh no something's really broken
you can always just uh
go on to any computer that has git right
and then say git clone that project and
it will take a copy of the product down
to that new computer
and then you can
edit the files save them git push and
push them back up there and then when
you get home back to your normal
computer you can say okay git pull
and it will pull down the latest version
onto your computer and update everything
so that means
you can work on any computer any folder
in your computer you know whatever you
want you can always just get the latest
version from the server work on that
code and then push it back to the server
and you always have a safe
safe version away from you in the future
i mean then we could talk about in
another video how teams are all pushing
and pulling to these remote servers and
that remote server is
being the place that
all the code comes together for the
company or the team or the projects
which you can get back to your computer
and now you've got a message from this
first hop go again
set the time to lift two it decrements
to one deck again and now
now you've got a similar problem on the
original ethernet back when you had a
shared physical piece of wine